[Music]
do you guys remember this graphics card
the GTX 1060 and the days when we used
to be able to get a card like this for
$200 or even the budget champion at this
time if you really wanted to get into PC
gaming you could get a GTX 1050t now
this thing was really good value and it
came at $140 or on the AMD side of
things you could pick up an rx480 or 580
but nowadays what are we getting a$ 1060
that went for $200 is now $300 in 2023
this is the entry point to get an Nvidia
graphics card AMD is basically doing the
same thing with their 7,000 series
graphics cards you can get the cheapest
one available is the RX 7600 and this
thing is
$270 this is confirmed like this is the
last card that AMD is going to be
introducing is that going to complete
the rdna 3 portfolio or is there maybe
more on the
horizon uh well the rdna 3 portfolio is
now complete really what what are your
options you have to pay that much or you
can try to scout some deals from the
last generation on Nvidia side of things
they offer an RTX 3050 and I wouldn't be
out here recommending the 3050 check out
these performance that Daniel Owen
showed for it on AMD side of things for
around that $200 price point should
really be getting the
6,600 nowadays so if you want a budget
entrylevel graphics card from the latest
gpus that are coming out what options
are there I mean there's really nothing
so here enters Intel wanting to fill
that underserved part of the market with
a budget GPU this is the ark a580 and
it's coming at at
$180 but just the sheer price of this
thing puts a smile on my face and it's
so freaking tiny and cute that doesn't
mean it's bad on performance it's just
so freaking cute but today what I want
to compare is the RX
6600 versus the a 580 from Intel let's
go ahead and start checking out these
graphics cards in some games and even in
productivity like blender and da Vinci
resolve for video editing and stuff
let's do that now in cyberpunk if you
play at 1080p on the high preset driving
through Dogtown here then you can see
these cards there's only a 2% difference
between them and if you bump up
cyberpunk to 1440p now these aren't
1440p graphics cards at all but you can
see that the ark a580 because of a
256bit memory bus it scales better when
you up the resolution because the memory
is faster also and this seems to be a
running Trend that Intel cards are
better at rate tracing you can see that
the 6600 with the RT medium press preset
in cyberpunk is 18% slower than the RK
a580 and if you hop into another game
like a plue tail recam we see that the
ark a580 also performs pretty well
against the 6600 the 6600 at 1080p on
the ultra quality scaling mode on the
high settings is 11% slower than the ark
a580 and if you just turn on Ray Trace
shadows in this game you can see that
6600 is 3 3% slower than the r a580
remember the 6600 costs $20 more than it
right now that's not a huge amount of
money but it's slower in certain cases
and that also includes a game like
Resident Evil 4 remake with the
prioritized Graphics preset at 1080p we
can see that the 6600 is 7% slower the
ark a580 and also if we go to 1440p it
is also slower but we can also see some
of the inconsistencies that come up with
the ark a580 if you turn on FSR quality
the 6600 runs away with the lead at
1440p prioritized graphics and I think
this is because it's a first generation
product or because I'm on a press driver
with the specific card that sometimes it
can just be a little buggy in fortnite
at 1080p on the high settings Ras dve so
no Lumin no right Tracer or anything in
direct X11 you see that the 6600 is 33%
faster than the arc a580 that is pretty
freaking significant yes the a580 is
still providing over 100 FPS at this in
this case but that doesn't really matter
when you know you can just get more with
the 6600 plus if you go to directx12 you
can see that the difference increases
even more and if you stay in direct X12
and turn on nanite and Lumen with unro
engine 5 and fortnite here you can see
the 6600 is 38% faster than the arc a580
and that is pretty significant when it
comes down to it but if you use the
hardware accelerated rate tracing for it
you can see that the 6600 is only 11%
faster here so because the raate tracing
is better on the Intel Arc card it can
kind of make up that Gap but you know
you could just use the software
accelerated version of nanite and Lum if
you really wanted that then another game
like Last of Us Part One we see some
more Oddities the 6600 is almost 30%
faster in this game and if you go up to
1440p I know you probably wouldn't use
these cards at 1440p we're not seeing
very good FPS really on either of them
but if you turn on FSR quality on the
high preset it's like the arc a580 just
doesn't really respond that well to the
upscaling and then if you turn off FSR
then it's
186% faster like this has to be a vram
issue going on here but the 6600 is just
way better in this case if you hop into
OverWatch 2 the 6600 is significantly
faster we're pulling in over 300 FPS
here which would means it give you the
ability to up settings and still get
high refresh rates on your monitor
whereas you can't do the same thing on
the a580 although these are still both
very good Esports cards in Remnant 2 the
a580 just seems like it's completely
broken in this at 1080p on the medium
preset not not anything demanding The
Arc a580 is only providing like a 33
average FPS and that means the 6600 is
is at 67 average FPS and it's 103%
faster than the arc a580 so the a580 can
be pretty inconsistent and have wild
performance differences in these cards
but I do have some hope that this a580
might perform a little bit better in the
future because in a lot of games the
a580 was struggling in completely the
a750 tends to perform a lot better in
those ones like Remnant 2 like in
Starfield it performs a lot better not
perfect but a decent chunk better so
what makes me hopeful is that because
the a750 is better in these games and
the a580 with some more driver updates
and stuff like that will also get better
over time I'm not 100% sure that's true
and you really shouldn't buy things off
of a promise although there is one area
where the ark a580 against the 6600
actually is is a pretty favorable
matchup and that comes into productivity
The Arc a580 at this budget $180 price
point does have av1 encoding and the RX
6600 just doesn't offer that because
it's not from the latest generation of
cards and if you compare these cards in
terms of rendering performance on h.265
then you can see that the ark a580 comes
in a lot faster than the RX 6600 we're
talking 4 minutes 52 seconds on the art
card versus 7 minutes on the the RX 6600
and that could definitely make a
difference in how you can render out
videos how you can edit videos and scrub
through the timelines and stuff like
that but it's not just rendering out
videos on the a580 here if we hop into
blender we're talking about
945 points on the monster Benchmark
versus
514 on the 6600 now the junk shop
Benchmark it's only 80 on the a580
versus 257 on the RX 6600 I don't know
exactly why that's the case if you guys
might know why that's the case let me
know but jump over to the classroom
Benchmark and the a580 is 489 points
versus 242 on the 6600 the ark a580 at
$180 might be the best card that you can
get in terms of productivity so I guess
I should also talk about the aib model
of card that I have here this is a
sparkle orc OC version of the a580 and
across all my testing this card performs
really freaking well it is very quiet
very cool most of the time the fans were
only spinning at like 1,400 RPM I think
or something like that there's this
interesting feature that the hotter the
card gets the the lights will change so
they start out blue then it goes to
yellow and then I think it goes to Red
if the car gets hot hot but mine never
even got that hot so it's only ever at
yellow for some reason it has two eight
pin connectors on it which rates this
card at 375 watts this card will never
draw that much power and if it does then
I am scared for you you would have a
bomb in your PC at that point in time
blue and black looks nice I can't hate
it whatsoever I I don't know how to say
sparkle actually did a really nice job
would I recommend the ark a580 at $180
it's it's difficult but at this current
moment in time I would say no because
it's just inconsistent there are
advantages to getting the ark a580 over
amd's competition even though it is a
little bit generally speaking slower in
gaming performance and I'll leave the
spreadsh sheeet of all of the games that
I tested and cards that I tested in the
description if you guys want to take a
closer look at them but but it if you
really need av1 encoding on a budget
with a card that can still game then the
the a580 is a good option you're still
getting 8 GB of vram you're getting fast
memory as well you know it's just the
inconsistency we'll have to see how that
improves over time hopefully it will
improve until it's very consistently
keeps updating their drivers for their
graphics cards so wouldn't surprise me
that this car gets some major
improvements in the future but at this
moment I just have some difficulty
recommending it to somebody on a budget
especially when you have another
graphics card like if this one doesn't
work in the game you know what else are
you going to use it's a budget card this
is your only option I think you want one
that is as reliable as you can possibly
get but at the very least it's exciting
to see a car coming into the market that
is
$180 and did put up a pretty good fight
against the AMD competition though I it
didn't really win let me know what you
guys think in the comments and yall have
a good rest of your day or whatever
you're doing see you in the next video
peace
n